the Joe Rogan experience Vinny what is
like when you've worked with so many
different people and there's so many
different psychological issues that
fighters deal with what do you think is
like one of the primary causes one of
the primary things that the
psychological missteps that fighters
make that you maybe could help them
correct things from the past I think I
think it's it's down to what goes on in
their lives before they may become
fighters yeah yeah how so um because I
don't think you can have only
relationship with anxiety unless
something's triggered it from the past
hmm
so I like to go deeper than just just
this surface I like to go back and sorts
of about the childhood and stuff like
that it seems to work but I think it's
my job Joe it's it's so interesting
because everyone's different you know
these you know one's got the same DNA or
the same fingerprints and everybody's
different to work with so to say one
thing could be very difficult it's just
about keeping them where they are
completely at one with the cells or the
understand the cells you know I mean and
not go down certain avenues of getting
carried away several example Adi told me
that we've want before one of his fights
in Mexico City I think it was it was
like it just praying or he was that
nervous it was praying that he just I
want to go to sleep because his mind was
so [ __ ] overactive and you know and
things like that I'm that's now working
with Cody no love Cody gavurin mm-hmm
and all they're all so different they're
all so talented and brilliant at what
they do but it's also different Easy's
that's just a nail it down to one thing
to be difficult but many times it's
memories of failure yeah reminder
because in the unconscious this is my
belief and people might argue with it
but I I think that you have to offer a
certain connection with something else
in the past to get yourself a reference
it's like I believe that anxiety is
something from the past thought about
now projected into the future mmm you
know sorry she acted into the future as
a zoomit Lee who you are finds you
projecting the future as in
you're gonna believe you're gonna lose
are you gonna do this so what we've done
now is just leave it on so what we've
both been doing is I've got a new thing
called a shaman solution where people
can go interactive website where they
can go on videos and it's like quite a
lot of videos of different what's the
URL the shaman solution.com yeah it's
not out yet it'll be out released also
when this comes out let me know
so I could send people there but yes
please the idea behind it is you can't
just do it in one session right you need
a bunch of it's like mental training
that's what pisses me off about fighters
yeah well they get constantly two weeks
before omiyo a new job blah blah blah
you know and are on the fight day I work
with Molly Makani had two fights
recently she went on but he was I had to
stop Starbucks from her kids and the
thing you get FaceTime and say blah blah
blah but I have work with Molly anyway
well people hire me after they lose hire
me before you lose so you can she can
you know get the best out your training
and stuff but that thing that's the
nature of the job I think it makes you
question yourself when you lose Brian so
but that can be great yeah it's great
for me but I mean no I mean even for
them
yeah it can be great to lose yeah
because it can give you a wake-up call
yeah and so many fighters have done
their best work after they've lost and
made adjustments yeah Mighty Mouse is a
great example tre when Mighty Mouse well
he beat ian mccall but honestly that is
a real questionable decision and ian was
beaten the [ __ ] out of them ian had his
back and he's pounded him in the head I
mean it was definitely his worst
performance or one of his worst
performances and then from then on
Mighty Mouse and Matt Hume had a
conversation like hey you can't just
[ __ ] half-ass this anymore yeah you
got to be all in yeah and he became all
in and then became the best - yeah
[Applause]